les traditionnels ot de pâques avec le
savoir-faire des grands maîtres
chocolatiers l'exemple à lyon de
bernaches ont le talent à déguster sans
modération
didier guyot olivier jacque là vous avez
du madagascar au dessus du venezuela
encore du venezuela
jamali jean-jacques bernachon une
institution sur lui on un débat
dériverait chocolatiers de france
chez lui tout est fertile en allemand à
partir des fèves de cacao aux multiples
araud la différence elle est déjà énorme
ans les taux refi on exhale des parfums
il reste alors à broyés et mélangés ce
qui peu à peu va devenir du chocolat
puis viennent les recettes maison sucre
cannelle vanille mais là on voit ce
discret
à
oh
bonjour pour un maître chocolatier
paquet un rendez vous primordial et tant
pis si l'on peut apparaître ringard mais
ce sont les oeufs les poules les cloches
que l'on propose tradition en
confisquant sera effective au fond moi
je conduis avec ça avec député la fin
aux états unis des forêts de chocolat au
xvème siècle christophe colomb découvre
les premières serres cinq siècles plus
tard la passion du chocolat est toujours
intacte communism on perd ce dont on
n'était pas trop mauvaise artisans ça
sûrement très amoureux industriel pas
changé ouvrir des boutiques partout dans
le monde des investisseurs lui ont
proposé mais de peur de perdre son âme
la maison bernachon a toujours refusé